Hi, in this class, we'll be learning some basics of performance profiling in Unreal Engine.
This will help us optimize our world building workflows and find performance bottlenecks
in our scene.
Now before we get started, I just wanted to point out that this class aims to only give
you a very quick overview of the profiling tunes in Unreal Engine.
We won't dive too deep today into this topic because we already have some courses specialized
and dedicated to it.
So if you want to get down to the nitty-gritty details of profiling in Unreal, I'd encourage
you to also check those out.
So what we mean by profiling is analyzing our projects used of system resources like
CPU, GPU processing, memory usage, or network bandwidth.
In Unreal, we have two main tools at our disposal to do that, the stat commands and Unreal Insights.
The stat commands are console commands we can type into the command prompt of our editor
and will display real-time performance information on our viewport, like how much memory we're
using, GPU and CPU load, and more.
There are a ton of stat commands we can type into the log, but today we're going to be
focusing on stat GPU profiling only.
Unreal Insights on the other hand helps find performance bottlenecks in our project by
showing us what's slowing things down, and is much more complete and detailed than the
profile GPU stat command.
So let's check out these couple of tools directly into the Engine.
Okay, we're into the assembly small map of the project that comes together with this
course.
Let's first start reviewing the stat GPU command.
So if we go down here, you will find the enter console command prompt.
And if we type stat GPU and then press enter, Unreal will display the GPU statistics of
whatever we have in frame on our viewport.
So if we move the camera around, you'll see this number changing slowly.
This tool is quite useful in a virtual production setting, because if your scene is running at
a low frame rate, you can easily identify what might be causing those frame drops.
The queue total number you see up here represents the time the GPU spends waiting for commands
to be processed in its render queue.
So if you see a really high number up here in a virtual production scene, this could
be causing latency issues.
So be mindful of that.
To stop the stat GPU command, you would just need to go down here into the console command.
And then if you press the up arrow, you will find the recently entered commands.
So you can just select the first one and then press enter again.
OK, next we will take a look at Unreal Insights.
And that's found down here under trace and clicking on Unreal Insights session browser.
It will open directly into the trace store window where we will find a log of all the
traces we performed in our session.
As you can see, I have performed a few ones when preparing this class.
But if we wanted to start a new tracing session, we could just click in this button down here
and Unreal will start tracing in the background.
And it will tell us trace started.
It's also a good idea to just move the camera around and focus on different areas of our
scene to get a complete performance analysis of our map.
Also zooming out and just viewing all the meshes we have down here might be a good idea.
Now in simple words, a tracing session will capture detailed performance data about our
map.
It creates basically a detailed log of everything happening under the hood that we simply can
playback and analyze to find performance problems.
OK, so if we wanted to stop the tracing session, we could just click on this red button down
here and this will stop tracing.
Now if we open up again the Unreal Insights session browser, we will find a new log down
here.
And if we simply double click on it, we will be able to open it up.
So in this timing insights window, we will be able to analyze all the collected performance
data in milliseconds.
What we're looking for if we pan with left click is actually areas of this log where
Unreal Engine sold a little bit.
You can see here that we have a high bar.
So this means that anything that was calculated here was probably pretty heavy.
And if I just zoom into it with my mouse wheel, I can actually just click on this high bar
and it's going to give me some further details.
Down here I can find the single processes of the GPU and the CPU.
And then here on the right, I can analyze the single elements and how long it took on
real to compute them.
We can also isolate the CPU and the GPU processes individually.
And up here we could also just toggle on and off different windows.
OK, I hope this brief introduction helps you getting a better understanding of profiling
performance in Unreal.
And now let's go back to the slides to conclude this video.
So that was it for this class.
But at this link you can find other extensive documentation and resources to learn more
about performance profiling, bad commands, and the Unreal Engine set-stool in Unreal Engine.
Unfortunately, we're almost at the end of this entire series of classes on world building
for virtual production.
We won't be diving into demos or theories any further.
But in the upcoming lesson, we will do a recap on everything we've learned so far and say
are goodbyes.
Thank you very much for sticking around.
And I'll see you there.
Bye.